Christopher Nolan is one of the rare
modern filmmakers with instantly
recognizable Styles but who is the man
behind the time bending plots dazzling
effects and Posh British accent Nolan
the man is actually way more relatable
than you'd suspect
Christopher Nola might seem exceedingly
British to the Casual observer in fact
he was born in London and speaks with a
British accent but he's only half
British while his father Brendan hailed
from the UK his mother Christina was
American because of this no leninist two
brothers Matthew and Jonathan have dual
citizenship in the United Kingdom and
the US when they were growing up the
families split their time between London
and Chicago but when Nolan began trying
to make movies he couldn't break into
the British film industry in an
interview with the guardian about those
early days Nolan said in England there's
a great suspicion of the new in cultural
terms that can be a good thing but when
you're trying to break into the film
industry it's definitely a bad thing he
felt Hollywood was more open to Fresh
talent and ideas so he and his family
settled in the Hollywood Hills but Nolan
hasn't abandoned his British point of
view his 2017 film Dunkirk about the
critical World War II battle was told
from the perspective of the Brits
stranded on French Shores there are four
hundred thousand men on this beach and
it just so happens to be the highest
gross interesting World War II movie of
all time George Lucas says game-changing
Blockbuster Star Wars Episode 4 A New
Hope became an important Touchstone to
millions of fans upon its release on May
25th 1977. one of them was
seven-year-old Christopher Nolan in an
interview at the 2015 Tribeca Film
Festival Nolan shared how Star Wars
inspired him to be a filmmaker saying I
would make these imaginatively titled
little science fiction films with a
Super 8 camera called space wars and
recently transferred them to DVD to
watch some of my children and I was
surprised to realize how bad they are
the 2018 book Christopher Nolan a
critical study of the films explains how
Nolan and his younger brother Jonathan
would use action figures as stop-motion
characters and build sets out of
household items like flower egg cartons
and toilet paper rolls but when asked if
had been interested in directing the
force awakens Nolan told The Daily Beast
as far as whether or not I would have
ever done it the truth is I think I'll
be afraid to touch it Christopher Nolan
is best known for the way he manipulates
time and perspective in his projects his
signature storytelling style non-linear
and often told to the lens of unreliable
narrators dates back to his earliest
work though than short films Doodlebug
and tarantula play with memory and point
of view in much the same way that later
features like insomnia Inception and
tenet do in order to build suspense and
create mystery Nolan's made such
narrative tricks his calling card but
those techniques have long been used in
detective novels to obscure the truth
from the reader until it's time for the
big reveal and the director has been a
lifelong crime fiction fan speaking with
the DGA quarterly in 2012 Nolan revealed
when I was 16 I read a Graham Swift
novel Waterland that did incredible
things with parallel timelines and told
a story in different dimensions that was
extremely coherent but though Nolan is a
writer his true medium is the screen and
he learned how to visually manipulate
time and perspective from a few seminal
late 20th century films including Blade
Runner the man who fell to Earth and and
Pulp Fiction when the time came to
choose a college major Christopher Nolan
didn't go to film school instead on his
father's advice he decided to study
English literature at University College
London but that doesn't mean he stops
loving or making movies Nolan chose UCL
specifically because it had a film
studio complete with a steam back
editing suite and 16 millimeter cameras
there was also a screening room and as
president of the UCL Film Society Nolan
got a program showings on some of his
favorite films and used the admission
charges to fund his work UCL ended up
being the right choice for Nolan for
personal and professional reasons he met
his longtime wife and producing partner
Emma Thomas on his first day at
University she continues to produce his
movies to this day and it involved in
every step of the process as his closest
creative Confidant the couple share four
children Flora Oliver Magnus and Rory
though he's one of the most artistically
and financially successful directors
working today Nolan endured a streak of
bad luck during the mid to late 90s when
he was living in London and looking for
a way into the industry around that time
his first attempt at a feature-length
film Larry Mahoney fizzled Nolan's
apartment was burglarized in an
interview at New York's IFC Center Nolan
reflected I realized the door was just
plywood and that was never keeping
anybody out what was keeping people out
was the social protocols that we have
that allow us to live together I was
interested in the certain types of
people who would stop observing those
protocols and why that would be
criminal is not complicated
what you really fear is inside yourself
he took what could have been a traumatic
experience and turned into the Catalyst
for a storied career with his wife Emma
Thomas producing and his friend Jeremy
Theobald in the lead role Nolan got to
work writing directing filming and
editing his debut feature following the
neo-noir film imagines what would happen
if a Down and Out writer began stalking
strangers for inspiration it was made
with practically no money estimates put
the budget at about three thousand
pounds out of necessity Nolan utilized a
non-linear storytelling structure black
and white film stock natural light
sources found locations and single takes
it paid off following earned attention
on the festival circuit and invited
comparisons to Alfred Hitchcock though
Christopher Nolan regularly commands
budgets of eight or nine figures he
insists that his biggest step up as a
director came between the Productions of
following and Memento he made the former
on his own dime while working a
full-time job but with momento he had
financing and was for the first time a
paid director I can't make new memories
everything just Fades he told DGA
quarterly the difference between
shooting following with a group of
friends wearing our own clothes and my
mum making sandwiches to spending four
million dollars of somebody else's money
on Memento and having a crew of 100
people is to this day by far the biggest
leap I've ever made burst Memento proved
to be a difficult sell even after
production was complete and everyone
agreed the film itself was fantastic
studio Executives heaped High Praise on
the concept performances and overall
quality of the finished product but they
thought the movie was too difficult to
Market and too confusing for average
audiences with no distribution deal
forthcoming Nolan's backers at Newmarket
films decided to release it themselves
the support of fans like Steven
Soderberg and great Word of Mouth turned
Memento into an instant cult classic it
went on to make nearly 40 million
dollars
after Memento became the Talk of the
Town Christopher Nolan and Emma Thomas
established their own production company
syncope films and bagana nearly
two-decade relationship with Warner
Brothers the Batman franchise have been
languishing in development limbo since
1997's poorly received Batman and Robin
until Nolan went to Warner Brothers to
pitch his concept of the character his
vision was dramatic and realistic not
campy and comic bookie his Batman was
deeply human Warner Brothers gave him a
deal then and there we weren't really
making a Batman movie
we're making a Chris Nolan movie 2005's
Batman Begins With a Triumph for both
Nolan and the studio but it was nothing
compared to the sequel that came three
years later The Dark Knight was a
cultural phenomenon critics and
audiences loved it by the winter of 2008
The Dark Knight was squarely in the
middle of the awards conversation when
the nominees for the 2009 Academy Awards
were announced the late Heath Ledger was
recognized for his portrayal of the
Joker and the film received eight nods
in total but none for best picture or
Best Director these stubs are still seen
as one of the Academy's worst oversights
attributed to bias against the genre
following the backlash the Oscars
expanded the best picture category from
5 to 10 nominees as of 2010. Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy stands on
its own as a cinematic achievement but
it's also part of the larger DC film
franchise but the DC movies have never
been able to pull off the same blend of
prestige and popularity that Nolan's
Trilogy or the best entries of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe can claim fans
might be surprised to learn Nolan has
been involved with DC Studios Beyond
History Batman entries he also produced
Zack Snyder's Man of Steel Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice and Justice
League now Lynn and Snyder are good
friends and he was originally brought on
to consultant Man of Steel and Batman
was introduced into Snyder's films Nolan
was happy to advise but he didn't feel
any ownership of the character
new rules
we're criminals Alfred if there's any
doubts of the past true friendship it
was Nolan who protected Snyder from
having to screen the just weed and curse
of Justice League after Snyder left the
project due to the tragic death of his
daughter when the pandemic have ended
the film industry each Studio had its
own way of coping some delayed films for
a year or more While others released
their movies via streaming or premium
video on demand Warner Brothers
eventually opted for a day and date
strategy in which films become available
in theaters and on streaming at the same
time in late summer 2020 one of Warner's
films Nolan's much anticipated tenet had
The Misfortune of Being the first major
motion picture to debut in theaters
after covert restrictions began to lift
but before Warner media's day-to-date
strategy was in place a test you passed
not everybody does tenants underwhelming
box office performance made sense given
that Cinemas in many major markets
including New York and China weren't
open yet but it was no longer going to
bath for filmmakers like James Gunn and
Denny villner that severed his
relationship with Warner media Nolan
publicly called out the studio after
they blindsided creatives with the
decision to release their 2021 slate of
titles on HBO Max on or shortly after
their theatrical premieres in a
statement to The Hollywood Reporter
Nolan said some of our industry's
biggest filmmakers and most important
movie stars went to bed the night before
thinking they were working for the
greatest movie studio and woke up to
find out they were working for the worst
streaming service these guys have given
a lot for these these projects and they
deserved to be consulted and spoken to
about what was going to happen to their
work shortly afterward Nolan announced
that they've been making his next film
Oppenheimer with universal he demanded a
100 plus day theatrical window out of
principle because Christopher Nolan has
made some of the most visually
spectacular films of the last 20 years
audiences might assume he's all in on
the latest Cutting Edge technology but
both in his personal and professional
life Nolan prefers to keep things analog
Chris is really great in that he wants
it for real he wants it in camera he
doesn't want to do CG Adobe films his
project specifically for iMac screens he
aims to capture as much as he can using
practical effects not only because it
looks more authentic but because
sometimes it's actually cheaper Nolan
infamously blew up a real Boeing 747 in
tenant for this reason and he recreated
something approximating a nuclear bomb
for Oppenheimer for the sake of
authenticity in his everyday life Nolan
is even less reliant on modern
technology he has neither a mobile phone
or an email address and intends to keep
it that way Nolan explained to The
Hollywood Reporter that cell phones
weren't as ubiquitous when he started
making movies in the 90s by the time
smartphones came around he'd made a name
for himself and could easily be reached
since everyone within his orbits had one
and could simply tap him on the shoulder
to get his attention as he says I
actually really like not having one
because it gives me time to think
[Music]